to sync your plancast calendar you'll
need to get your unique calendar URL
here's how to do it sign into plancast
go to profile and rightclick the
calendar icon at the top right click
copy shortcut from the
menu it's important you do this from the
profile section so that you only get
your events and not the events of all
the people you subscribe
to now sign into tungl me go to
management and select synced from the
menu click add new calendar and contact
sync Source select Plan cast from the
popup name your calendar paste in the
link you copied from plancast and click
add
Source your plancast calendar is now
synced note that the tungl me sync with
plancast is
readon that means you'll be able to see
your plancast events in tungl me and
your availability will be updated as you
add new events to
plancast but tungl me will not be able
to add new events booked through tungl
me to your plancast
calendar